une réforme souhaitée par tous mais à
des conditions différentes
face à un calendrier serré les congés
parlementaires débutant d'ici une
semaine difficile d'imaginer un accord
entre républicains et démocrates
les deux camps estime nécessaire une
révision des règles imposées à la police
américaine
problème les divergences sont profondes
sur le contenu de la loi
parmi les points d'achoppement figurent
notamment l'immunité des policiers et la
proscription de la clé d'étranglement
lors des interpellations
c'est le jazz floyd justin policing acte
n'a que très peu de chances d'être
validée dans sa forme actuelle au sénat
majoritairement républicains les
démocrates se sont félicités ce jeudi de
ce premier pas en avant
[Musique]
nous allons faire un grand pas en avant
dans ce mouvement aujourd'hui car 231
parlementaires ont co parrainer la loi
de georges floyd sur la justice dans le
maintien de l'ordre
nous allons maintenant la soumettre au
débat et commencer le processus de
transformation du maintien de l'ordre en
amérique avec georgia justin policing
acte la chambre rend hommage à sa vie et
celle de tous ceux qui ont été tués par
les violences policières et promet plus
jamais ça le texte ne cite pas le même
engouement dans le camp républicain
un premier projet initié par les
sénateurs du parti de donald trump jugé
trop limité par les démocrates a été
bloqué la veille par ces derniers en
réaction à ce barrage au sénat le
locataire de la maison blanche a dénoncé
la volonté du camp adverse d'affaiblir
la police les républicains du sénat soit
vivement adopté un projet de loi sur la
réforme de la police nous avons une
coopération totale avec de nombreuses
communautés différentes y compris la
communauté policière démocrates ne
veulent pas ça ils veulent enlever
beaucoup de force à notre police et aux
forces de l'ordre en général et nous ne
pouvons pas vivre avec ça nous ne
pouvons pas vivre et que ça c'est un
excellent projet de loi fortement
soutenu par comme vous savez team scot
qui est formidable qui est un homme
formidable un grand sénateur mais nous
ne ferons pas
sacrifice ne ferons pas cela nous ne
ferons rien qui puisse nuire à notre
police les débats devraient se
poursuivre entre parlementaires dans les
prochains mois pour un sujet qui à n'en
pas douter restera en première ligne
dans la suite de la campagne américaine